j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
vous le savez on choisit le plus souvent
possible volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour et on revient ce
soir avec le recul du temps de quelques
semaines sur la brouille entre la France
et l'Allemagne pourquoi le duo
traditionnel moteur de l'Europe a-t-il
des raté avant d'attendre nos experts un
premier constat celui d'un chancelier
allemand qui joue sa carte sur le plan
international Flora sauvage
l'inflation galope et les prix de
l'énergie pour suivre leur envolée face
aux difficultés qui s'accumulent en
Europe l'Allemagne est accusé de faire
cavalier seul au premier rang des sujets
qui fâchent le plan de soutien de 200
milliards d'euros à l'économie allemande
c'est un choix qui a été fait sans
concertation avec les partenaires
européens à cela s'ajoute le fait que
l'Allemagne a choisi alors elle va
probablement changer sa position là dans
les prochains jours mais jusque là elle
refusait d'appliquer un plafonnement des
prix du gaz donc elle protégeait à la
fois son économie tout en maintenant une
forme de concurrence avec les autres sur
le nucléaire l'énergie ou l'armement les
divergences s'accumulent entre Paris et
Berlin je vais travailler avec autre
chose je pense que ce n'est pas bon ni
pour l'Allemagne ni pour l'Europe quel
s'isole début novembre Olaf Jones s'est
rendu à Pékin car la Chine est le
premier partenaire commercial de
l'Allemagne mais ce voyage a suscité de
nombreuses critiques la jouer solo c'est
clairement un mauvais signal en ce
moment maintenant on a aussi nous de
notre côté multiplier les voyages en
solitaire
différents pays dont les régimes ne sont
pas toujours recommandables maintenant
c'est vrai que depuis un certain temps
on se réveille vis-à-vis de la Chine on
sort d'une certaine forme de naïveté et
que là le message le signal envoyé par
la chose est clairement une erreur
politique alors que les divergences
entre Paris et Berlin ont conduit au
report du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand les sujets de défense
sont au cœur des désaccords l'Allemagne
a dévoilé son projet de bouclier
antimissiles qui s'appuie sur des engins
américains et israéliens sur les
questions de défense on a tendance à
sous-estimer en France le poids de la
relation transatlantique dans la prise
de décision en Allemagne pour les
Allemands le partenaire transatlantique
il est indispensable il assure sa
sécurité et la vision stratégique de
l'Allemagne qui s'est développée depuis
la seconde la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale elle est vraiment dans cette
optique là et c'est vrai que nous on
parle souvent du couple franco-allemand
je trouve que le terme de couple il est
un peu trompeur parce que on a tendance
à penser que tout va être pensé à l'aune
de la relation franco-allemande chez les
allemands alors que ce n'est même pas le
cas chez nous au ou la guerre est aux
portes de l'Europe il reste quelques
semaines à Paris et Berlin pour tenter
de trouver un terrain d'entente avant le
mois de janvier date du 60e anniversaire
du traité de l'Élysée qui avait scellé
la réconciliation entre la France et
l'Allemagne
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce débat et demi de la
Croix bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur à Sorbonne université
spécialiste de l'Allemagne contemporaine
Chloé Ridel bonsoir bienvenue aussi
directrice adjointe de l'Institut
Rousseau auteur de d'une guerre à
l'autre publiée aux éditions de l'eau de
Brita senberg bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir
vous êtes la directrice du bureau de Der
Spiegel à Paris Laetitia cruppa éditeur
est petit qui est resté évidemment à mes
côtés peut-être un premier tour de table
en réaction à notre à notre sujet est-ce
que vous diriez que l'Allemagne la joue
solo ou que Olaf Scholtz la joue solo
les lumières de la croix et si oui
pourquoi
alors quand on dit il y a un temps de
reproche quand on dit l'Allemagne la
joue solo il faut quand même je vais
essayer pour une fois de plus le solo un
gouvernant un chef de gouvernement il
est il a été élu pour servir son pays et
son pays se trouve dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée et il aurait en
effet été raisonnable de chercher des
appuis et notamment de parler à devoir
le choix a été fait on l'a expliqué dans
le sujet avant de d'aller en Chine alors
que le président Macron estimait que
c'était trop tôt oui c'est un choix qui
a été fait avec des intérêts allemands
en premier d'abord on ne peut pas
l'emblamer c'est vrai que si dans cette
situation un petit peu de panique il y a
quand même un petit peu chaotique cette
période depuis le mois de février 2022
on pourrait attendre du partenaire
allemand qu'il est systématiquement le
réflexe franco-allemand comme a pu la
voir en son temps le grand exemple le
mot de colle même si si on regarde un
peu dans le passé il a fait aussi
quelques fois le cavalier seul et ça a
provoqué de la même façon des
grincements entre la France et
l'Allemagne à ce couple ou duo
franco-allemand et au prédécesseurs de
d'Emmanuel Macron et de l'absol mais
vous faisiez référence à février 2022
évidemment le la guerre en Ukraine Chloé
d'elle ça représente quoi pour le modèle
allemand à quel point ça bouleverse le
modèle allemand mais ça le ça le
bouleverse totalement l'Allemagne
traverse une crise de modèles majeur et
d'ailleurs ola Scholl depuis le 24
février devant le bundestal le 27
février le 27 février a parlé de
changement d'époque en disant qu'il
fallait arrêter de dépendre notamment de
régime autoritaire pour de ces relais de
croissance l'Allemagne est dans une
situation de dépendance vis-à-vis de la
Chine c'est son premier partenaire
commercial sauf qu'il a du mal à
accorder les actes à la parole
et ça je trouve que c'est très
dommageable je pense que davantage
qu'une crise entre la France et
l'Allemagne c'est une crise pour
l'Allemagne fondamentale parce qu'elle
sait qu'elle doit changer de modèle un
modèle de croissance fortement tourné
l'exportation et tout le reste en
découle le fait d'être etif à
l'inflation le fait d'être attentif aux
déficit budgétaires et aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne doit changer de modèle parce
que ce modèle entre en conflit direct
avec l'intérêt général européen et avec
l'objectif d'une autonomie stratégique
européenne parce que si demain l'Europe
peut être autonome veut promouvoir les
droits humains un peu promouvoir le
progrès écologique dans le monde elle a
pas 36 armes à son actif elle en a une
c'est son marché et sa capacité à peser
sur le reste du monde va dépendre de
l'ouverture fermeture de son marché il y
a quelques semaines l'Europe a pris un
règlement contre la déforestation qui
interdit l'entrée dans le marché
européen de tous les produits qui sont
issus de la déforestation dans le monde
ça c'est une arme majeure écologique ça
a un impact sur le reste du monde mais
ça ça comment dire si vous avez la
première économie européenne qui dépend
de de ces exportations et qui a intérêt
à un modèle libre-échangiste vous ne
pouvez pas activer cette arme là donc il
faut que l'Allemagne arrête de commercer
davantage avec le reste du enfin trop et
surtout avec des régimes motoritaires
comme la Chine qu'elles se recentre sur
l'Europe et qu'elle change son modèle
industriel sont issus qui ne doit plus
être concentrés que autour de
l'automobile ou de la chimie mais son
aimant savoir faire que le met au
service de ce dont l'Europe a besoin
pour demain les énergies renouvelables
les matériaux qu'on voit l'ampleur du
défi quand même dans ce que dans ce que
vous nous décrivez Brita sender comment
sont perçus les les premiers mois de de
l'absolt en Allemagne quel bilan en
quelque sorte pour sa première année au
pouvoir est-ce qu'il reste populaire
comment c'est perçu c'est assez mitigé
il y a beaucoup d'Allemands qui seront
moins bienveillants que vous par rapport
à ce qu'il fait donc la cette visite en
Chine par exemple a été regardé d'un œil
très critique aussi la les
maladresses par rapport à la France
c'était nous l'engage pig on les a
décrit et on a dit que c'était pas
vraiment ce qu'il fallait faire moi je
crois qu'il y a toujours eu dans le
couple franco-allemand des des points de
vue qui était assez différents au niveau
contenu on n'a jamais enfin même dans
les meilleurs couples n'hésitez pas
d'accord sur tous les points mais la
grande différence c'était et ce sont
expliqués ils ont communiqué et moi je
crois que pour moi il y a eu plusieurs
événements maintenant dans ces dernières
semaines qui étaient troublant pour les
Français ou pour la France ou perturbant
dans les décisions les actes la
communication est-ce que Scholl ça dit
c'est ma première visite dans ma
fonction en tant que chancelier est-ce
que Emmanuel Macron étant élu président
il aurait voulu faire sa première visite
en Chine avec le chancelier ou la
chancelière je sais pas mais bon moi je
ne défends pas qu'il a fait comment il a
fait mais il avait des raisons donc
éventuellement vous auriez pu en avoir
les mêmes mais le problème à mon avis
c'est comme avec ces 200 milliards qui
étaient annoncés pour
équilibrer les frais d'énergie il faut
expliquer pourquoi la France a dit on
sait pas pour pour quel but cet argent
et dépensé et on se sent dépassé pas
informé c'est pas excès il manque des
explications et moi je crois que c'est
ça vraiment de points le plus important
c'est à dire que on a toujours eu des
différences mais on sait mieux expliquer
et on a mieux pas parler on a mieux
échangé nos différents et nos différents
points de vue alors on parle d'une
brouille franco-allemande le titre de
notre débat c'est brouille ou divorce on
va on va pouvoir avancer sur cette cette
réflexion ensemble l'un des symptômes de
cette bouille c'est le report d'un
conseil des ministres communs qui était
prévu à Fontainebleau et en marge du
dernier sommet de l'Union européenne le
président de la République français
évidemment a tenté de déminer on
l'écoute
chacun d'abord sur le plan national fait
les choses je pense que c'est toujours
mieux de se consulter de ce coordonnées
après je pense que nous avons besoin à
manier France de renforcer la
souveraineté européenne et moi j'ai
toujours considéré comme mon devoir
était de tout faire pour que nous
trouvions les chemins d'accord entre
l'Allemagne et la France qui permettent
ensuite de bâtir des accords européens
donc je suis à la tâche mais ne voyez là
qu'un report technique si je puis dire
enfin nous avons beaucoup de travail
devant nous alors quelle importance on
est à quel degré de gravité c'est en
quelque sorte un peu ça la question et
l'ennemir de la Croix brouillou divorce
elle a le président français a appris la
leçon de l'histoire franco-allemande
c'est à dire qu'il dit exactement ce
qu'il faut dire il a raison c'est à dire
qu'il faut communiquer et on sait très
bien dans l'histoire des relations
franco-allemandes que à partir du moment
où en effet on ne se parle pas il y a
des mésentent des mes accords et je
parlais tout à l'heure d'elmoulko je
pense que l'exemple qu'il y a qui a pu
exister c'était quand le chancelier Cole
avait annoncé le son plan en 10 points
vers la réunification le 28 novembre 89
sans avoir devenu le président français
ça a été vraiment le point de départ
d'une brouille qui a duré vraiment
plusieurs semaines donc c'est je vois
parfaitement d'accord avec vous c'est un
problème de communication
je suis pas sûr que j'irai pas dans le
dans le vocabulaire de la de la brouille
de la dispute etc ce sont des désaccords
c'est un froid mais on peut faire
confiance pour une tentative de reprise
de contact le problème c'est aussi
qu'ils n'ont pas le recul d'un
savoir-faire à deux et il faut l'ajouter
le problème c'est que Olaf schols et à
l'intérieur aussi considéré comme
parfois je vais oser le mot un peu
autiste c'est-à-dire un peu incapable de
communiquer
il est on dit pauvre en mot en allemand
c'est à dire que il pas m'ont disait
déjà de la Merkel qu'elle parlait très
très peu lui il est capable de répondre
à une question par oui
et ne pas expliquer à l'intérieur de sa
collision quelles peuvent être les
divergences qu'il peut y avoir parce que
c'est aussi une des nodée mais je pense
que la façon dont il est dans ce type de
situation est la porte ouverte à des
malentendus et a peut-être des
surréactions de la part des
interlocuteurs qui auraient préférés
qu'on leur explique un couple il faut
être complémentaire donc il faut se
parler justement c'est intéressant parce
qu'on va faire un peu de sémantique au
cours de le mot couple il est il y a de
l'affectif dedans
c'est un mot français on le traîne
depuis le début j'allais dire et alors
il a eu un avantage dans la mesure où il
permet de communiquer dans l'opinion
publique l'idée que on a dépassé les
prétendues querelles intestines depuis
toujours
admiréditaire etc et que on marche main
dans la main c'est cette image là qui a
été énormément d'ailleurs travaillé par
les par les dirigeants sauf que
qu'est-ce qu'on dit en Allemagne
évidemment autant de Merkel et Macron on
disait couple puisque c'était un homme
une femme
allemande je crois qu'il faut pas
s'arrêter à ces mots et à ce vocabulaire
c'est autre chose qui compte et on aime
bien dire que les Allemands le
conçoivent d'une façon technique ils
disent moteur et que le moteur ne marche
plus voilà on est dans on est dans notre
dans notre bison à vision un peu biaisée
on va faire le couple il faut plus
penser à la dimension j'allais dire même
physique c'est-à-dire qu'un couple c'est
pouvoir faire un levier pour faire
avancer les choses et c'est exactement
ce qu'elle dit Emmanuel Macron c'est
l'idée d'un attelage de deux pays qui
ont des intérêts divergents et c'est
comme ça je veux dire on peut vouloir
changer les choses les structures et les
intérêts sont divergents il faut essayer
par un attelage de tirer ensemble dans
le même sens même si on n'est pas
exactement identique alors si on analyse
cette boucle ridelle pour pourquoi ce
conseil des ministres franco-allemand
c'est toujours un moment symbolique
important pourquoi il a été reporté il y
a des raisons objectives parce que les
conditions étaient pas réunies pour que
on puisse communiquer sur d'éventuelles
accords etc moi je pense que plutôt
qu'une brouille il y a une confrontation
cette confrontation elle existe depuis
le départ puisque nos deux pays ont non
seulement des intérêts qui sont souvent
opposés nous sommes rarement d'accord et
j'ai eu à en connaître directement au
sein de l'État français mais nous avons
aussi des cultures politiques
extrêmement différentes donc nous c'est
la raison pour laquelle le général de
Gaulle a mis en place le traité de
l'Élysée et dont découle c'est ces
conseils des ministres franco-allemand
c'est une déclinaison du traité de
l'Élysée parce que justement avec
quelqu'un avec qui vous n'êtes jamais
d'accord il y a une exigence de dialogue
supplémentaire donc là on est dans une
période de confrontation ouverte alors
que ces dernières années elle était
plutôt larvée mais moi je pense que
c'est bien parce que c'est le moment de
mettre la pression sur l'Allemagne pour
que elle change ses pratiques et son
modèle je rappelle que l'un des derniers
actes de l'air Merkel ça a été de signer
un accord d'investissement avec la Chine
extrêmement déséquilibrée en faveur de
l'Europe et ça fait 6 ans qu'Emmanuel
Macron nous parle d'autonomie
stratégique européenne sans jamais
parler de l'éléphant dans la pièce aka
l'Allemagne qui empêche cette autonomie
stratégique européenne puisque si
l'Europe est dépendante tout azimut des
États-Unis pour sa sécurité de la Russie
pour son gaz et de la Chine pour ses
déboucher industriels c'est à cause des
choix stratégiques allemands donc
maintenant si Emmanuel Macron est
cohérent avec lui-même il faut qu'il
rentre dedans à ola Scholt pour le
pousser à faire ce qu'il dit qu'il
ferait c'est-à-dire le changer même
encore un petit peu plus loin il faut il
faut mettre la pression mais pas que la
France parce que pardon l'ensemble de
l'Europe Patty de latitude de
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui du fait qu'elle
se comporte comme un hédémone sans
assumer de leadership qui implique une
responsabilité l'Allemagne bloque à
bloqué pendant des mois un plafonnement
des prix du gaz en Europe elle a préféré
laisser filer les prix parce que sa
priorité à elle c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et elle a peur que
si on plafonne les prix les fournisseurs
à ivoire ailleurs et donc du coup elle
laisse filer les prix et puis elle fait
un chèque de 200 milliards pour
subventionner son industrie parce
qu'elle en a les moyens mais les autres
n'ont pas les moyens on était 24 pays
europ dire à demander ce plafonnement
donc c'est pas que la France aujourd'hui
qui doit mettre la pression autre pays
laisse faire l'Allemagne mais il le
laisse pas faire le simplement ils ont
pas le même poids politique que nous
vous voyez donc nous on a on a on a des
liens politiques mais la Pologne
regardez ce que fait la Pologne de façon
extrêmement agressive d'ailleurs demande
des réparations de l'ordre de plusieurs
peut-être que vous pourrez en parler
mieux que moi des réparations de guerre
parce que demande la Pologne aujourd'hui
donc non il y a d'autres pays qui qui se
joignent à nous pour dire qu'il faut que
l'Allemagne change de modèle et je crois
qu'il faut avoir conscient des
difficultés qu'elle fait face et
l'accompagner vers ce changement quitte
à la financé pour cela enfin voilà
réfléchir à des choses mais mettre les
sujets sur la table c'est nécessaire on
va faire un peu un peu d'histoire
prendre un peu de recul aussi grâce à
vous Laetitia puisque on vous aime nous
démontrer que le couple franco-allemand
ou le duo ou le moteur est un mythe
construit et pensé par les deux pays la
love story carrément parce que ça a été
romancé ça a été pensé bien sûr depuis
60 ans depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale le message envoyé au
monde entier par ces deux ces deux
nations a été travaillées ensemble et
c'est le général de Gaulle qui
finalement attendu le premier Lama en
recevant Adenauer dans sa résidence de
Colombelles et deux églises c'est un
acte fort un acte politique mais un
symbole fort de cette finalement
réconciliation franco-allemande on est
le 14 septembre 1958 la télé est déjà là
et filme à la poignée de main entre les
deux chefs d'État vous pouvez le voir et
puis rapporte que les deux hommes se
sont mis d'accord pour ce sont des
termes de la télévision à l'époque
travailler côte à côte alors l'idée bien
sûr c'est de mettre en scène cette
entente cordiale après 70 ans qui ont vu
quand même ces deux pays s'affrontés au
cours de trois guerres et dont la
dernière 39 45 laisse encore des
stigmates douloureux encore aujourd'hui
dans les mémoires collectives alors donc
là on est en 58 ensuite le message va
évoluer
tactile et contrairement aux habitudes
il n'y a pas eu de conférence de presse
commune ce jour-là mais simplement des
mots des mots qui n'ont pas été dit mais
des mots qui ont été écrits au lâche
scholls à tweeté que c'était une bonne
et importante conversation quand les
lisait communiquer sur une rencontre
très constructive est-ce que c'est pour
autant la fin de l'amitié je ne sais pas
mais ça y ressemble quand même un peu
pour le moment mais après les symboles
les signaux les mots ont été tellement
nombreux dans les messages envoyés aux
opinions publiques mondiales et aux
opinions publiques de nos pays
respectifs que l'arsenal de
communication est prêt à tout moment à
être réactivé à quel point Brita sender
l'aspect personnel parce que on peut pas
gommer ça on parle de duo on parle de
couple franco-allemand les relations
personnelles entre deux un chef d'État
d'à côté un chef de gouvernement de de
l'autre à quel point ça joue toujours
important comme dans toutes les
relations politiques mais je voudrais
revenir enfin
l'amitié oui c'est l'amitié et je trouve
que c'est un peu facile de le réduire à
la rhétorique puisqu'il y a une vraie
proximité il y a une vraie amitié entre
les Français et les Allemands et on
regarde l'histoire reste dans l'histoire
évidemment mais enfin quand vous
regardez d'où on vient et où on est
quand vous demandez les Allemands à ce
que quand la France et les français pour
eux de quel pays de quel peuple ils se
sont proches vous allez avoir les mêmes
réponses donc je trouve que c'est un peu
facile de réduire ça à un niveau
rhétorique tout d'abord deuxièmement oui
évidemment les relations compte toujours
là en sortait d'une relation de deux
personnes qui étaient des parties
différentes mais qui se sont vraiment
aimés je crois et bien entendu Emmanuel
Macron ça fonctionnait bien ils sont
très différents mais ça fonctionne bien
depuis le début mais après je crois
qu'il y avait une certaine fascination
de la part de la mer que pour ce jeune
président qui ne qui n'avait pas peur
qui osait tout qui voulait aller vite
qui allait devant donc complètement le
contraire de ce pense que ce que le
caractérise mais comme souvent ça et
puis lui il a dû avoir du respect pour
cette femme que tout le monde en Europe
respectait écouté et qui enfin bon on a
vu je crois là par exemple dans sur
plein d'images qui avaient une vraie
proximité et sympathie bon maintenant
olafolls et je dirais peut-être pas
autiste comme vous mais quelqu'un de
très réticent et je crois que il a fait
l'erreur maintenant dans ces dernières
semaines de ne pas se rendre compte des
sensibilités de l'autre côté du côté
français parce que je crois que beaucoup
de choses auraient pu être évitées et
quand vous avez demandé pourquoi ce
conseil ministre a été annulé je crois
que les dernières la dernière goutte
c'était que les 200 milliards étaient
annoncés ce paquet pour l'énergie le
chef de la Chancellerie était quelques
jours avant à Paris enfin le
l'équivalent de votre Lexus oculaire il
a rencontré plein de personnes à
l'Élysée il a rien dit ils auraient pu
dire quand même nous ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est ça cette attitude
moi je crois que c'est vraiment je
dirais pas que c'est la mauvaise volonté
je crois que enfin quelqu'un de la Cedeo
à droite c'est l'incompétence
psychologique et communicatif ce qui est
pas non plus très gentil je crois que
c'est plutôt moi parfois j'ai
l'impression que cette nouvelle
chancellerie s'enferme un peu dans une
bulle et moi réceptif par rapport au
Conseil de l'extérieur mais à tout le
point de vue pas seulement dans ses
rêves
du président français et de l'Elysée
mais après plusieurs années de pouvoir
donc là c'est un peu tôt pour essayer
enfermer dans cette
on pourrait prudement dire arrogance
peut-être on sait mieux on va faire mais
je crois qu'ils ont sous-estimé qu'il
faut quand même informer et quand on
vient quand on regarde d'où on venait
c'est-à-dire que Merkel et Macron s'est
changé parfois quotidiennement plusieurs
fois par SMS d'une façon très très
direct en anglais donc voilà le tout est
quand même rendu difficile par la
situation qu'on connaît tous la crise
économique la guerre donc c'est pas
simple non plus et puis il y a une
dimension vous lui intervenir de la
croix c'est peut-être pas la question
que vous attendez mais je vais vous la
poser et puis pour vous pourrez faire un
mix des deux mais le vous parlez
d'Angela Merkel c'est cette longévité
qui lui donnait quand même une aura
internationale il faut pas sous-estimer
pour la Scholtz l'enjeu de de s'imposer
aussi dans des sommets là il y a eu il y
a le G20 ou dans les premiers sommets
européens c'est pas c'est pas neutre
dans la relation entre Macron qui lui
est là déjà depuis cinq ou six ans et un
Olaf schols qui arrive oui d'autant que
si on prend son strict point de vue il
était pas prévu qu'il devienne
chancelier c'est un petit peu parce que
la Cedeo a trébuché que qu'il a pu se
retrouver
à la tête d'une nouvelle coalition il a
eu cette chance il a fallu du temps pour
établir un contrat de coalition ce qui
dure toujours en Allemagne et à peine
était-il chef du gouvernement que les
grands projets qu'ils avaient réussi à
élaborer ensemble on est dû être de leur
sont tombés sur les pieds d'une certaine
façon à partir du moment où l'Ukraine a
été attaquée par par la Russie je pense
que c'est très important ce que vous
avez dit et on sous-estime parce qu'on
dit toujours le couple on voit le
chancelier le président les entourages
et je crois que la Chancellerie
actuellement en Allemagne est un exemple
typique de la capacité à enfermer un
chef de gouvernement sans lui donner les
informations indispensables qu'il
faudrait je pense qu'il a c'est un peu
le syndrome que le reproche toujours à
l'Elysée qui est un peu arrogant aussi
vis-à-vis de des Affaires étrangères en
Allemagne on a vu ces dernières années
au cours des ans depuis la fin de d'Elmo
de Call une fleuriste autonomie de la
Chancellerie laissant aux Affaires
étrangères un rôle assez secondaire
d'autant plus que la ministre d'affaires
étrangère n'alena berbock a depuis le
début montrer qu'elle avait de la
personnalité des principes et qu'elle ne
se laissait pas marcher sur les pieds et
il est il semble je ne vois pas d'autre
explications à cette incompréhension
qu'avait de la situation et du du
caractère enfin que ce que c'était
complètement minet lorsqu'il est arrivé
à Paris je n'ai pas d'autres explication
que il n'est pas été informé conseillé
suffisamment bien et le fait que là il
n'est pas eu de conférence de presse on
l'a tous interprété comme une mesure de
rétorsion de la part de l'Élysée alors
que si j'ai bien compris le chancelier
était venu avec des journalistes et
attendait à une mise en scène et on lui
a fait bien comprendre que non là vous
avez mal mesuré le le situations
à votre expérience de de l'intérieur
vous avez travaillé avec avec les
équipes de Scholl tu vois oui évidemment
en fait j'allais dire mais je reprends
la question de l'amitié dont on parle
finalement et qui qui sous-tend cette
partie de l'émission quand vous êtes
avec vos interlocuteurs d'un staff
ministériel à l'autre
c'est un ami c'est un concurrent et
c'est quoi en fait la relation en fait
moi c'est vrai que j'ai travaillé donc
j'ai servi la direction générale du
Trésor et le pendant allemand c'est le
BMF donc le ministère des Finances
allemands et j'allais dire du BMF
puisqu'il était ministre des Finances il
a amené avec lui à la Chancellerie celui
qui était alors son directeur général du
Trésor donc le chef de l'administration
des finances s'appelle genre cookies et
comment dire les relations entre le
Trésor français et le trésor allemand
sont exécrables parce que c'est les
sujets les plus difficiles qui touchent
à la monnaie qui touche à la dette aux
déficit donc c'était toujours des
discussions extrêmement acrimonieuses et
peut-être que ils ont emporté à la
Chancellerie cette culture de la
confrontation aussi et de la défiance
vis-à-vis de la France héritée de la
culture du BMF qui est profondément
défiante c'est vrai vis-à-vis de des
services français il y a une forme aussi
de comment dire le BMF si vous voulez
c'est le temple de ce qu'on appelle le
schwartenolo donc la politique de zéro
noir du Zéro déficit pour eux on est des
espèces de mauvais élèves de menteurs de
gens qui ne respectent pas les règles
donc c'est toujours été des discussions
très difficiles avec eux on parle
clairement pas la même langue en fait
donc je pense qu'il est aussi le symbole
l'héritier de ça quoi il apporte à la
Chancellerie des méthodes de travail
qu'il a appris en tant que ministre des
Finances qui sont pas forcément les plus
comment propices à la bonne entente avec
la France
cette bonne marche du duo
franco-allemand elle est évidemment
scrutée en France et sous un enjeu de
bataille politique et de critique pour
le pouvoir en place la preuve avec le
président LR de la commission des
affaires européennes au Sénat en
françois Rapin je vous propose de
l'écouter les temps ont changé
l'Allemagne ne s'excuse plus elle
s'affirme et la France est à sa remorque
déjà distancier en matière économique
notre pays risque à présent le
déclassement diplomatique tout ceci
parce que l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne va recentrer géopolitiquement
l'Allemagne au centre de l'Europe
est-elle capable l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
de mieux articuler ses intérêts propres
avec l'intérêt stratégique supérieur que
nos deux pays partagent une Europe de la
paix et de la liberté Brita cette
histoire de bascule géographique
non on n'est pas dans cet état d'esprit
sur ce plateau loin de là mais est-ce
que c'est c'est perçu commenté
finalement
accepté en Allemagne cette idée là c'est
à dire que le centre de gravité de
l'Europe est en train un peu de bouger
et donc ça place l'Allemagne un peu plus
au centre du jeu l'Allemagne c'est
toujours je crois que les Allemands
ressentent moins se basculement que vous
d'accord puisque l'allemand c'est
toujours senti proche de la puisqu'on
avait dans notre propre pays laisse on
avait deux pays donc il y a pas si
longtemps 89 quand on reprenait
l'histoire c'est pas très long donc moi
je crois que évidemment c'est toujours
senti plus proche de l'Est qui était un
avantage aussi puisque si on reprend le
couple une repartition de rôle Merkel
était toujours plus apte à parler aux
pays de l'Est et la France au pays du
Sud Méditerranée donc c'était un
avantage céleste en plus elle elle avait
une crédibilité en plus étant une
ancienne allemande de l'est
donc maintenant c'est le cours de
l'Histoire qui fait que que l'est enfin
qui a ce changement géopolitique comment
se positionner par rapport à ça les
Français sont plus réticents méfiants
l'Allemagne a quand même fait enfin
compris à aimer émis un signal qu'ils
ont compris en disant que tout ne soit
pas ne doit pas être voté à l'unanimité
une fois qu'on aura élargi pour pour
éviter les situations de blocage la
question c'est qu'est-ce qui est
l'alternative est-ce qu'on peut laisser
une partie de l'Europe
à l'extérieur est-ce que est-ce qu'il
vaut pas mieux
l'Ukraine et la Moldavie ont déjà
maintenant le statut de candidat ont
commencé c'est un long processus
qu'est-ce qui est l'alternative à ça et
est-ce que la thématique de risque pas
non plus des nouvelles déchirures donc
donc c'est vu d'une façon critique aussi
en Allemagne mais je crois que la
question de quelle est l'alternative ça
pose d'une façon plus qu'ici peut-être
on va parler des choix militaires de
l'Allemagne dans un très court instant
mais je voudrais vous entendre et venir
de la Croix là-dessus sur la question du
centre de gravité peut-être je sais pas
d'une alternative au couple ou audio
franco-allemand c'est quand on est
historien et qu'on entend cette scène on
se dit tiens on est peut-être en 1990 ou
tiens nous sommes peut-être même en 1970
lors de l'os polytique c'est-à-dire que
c'est aussi une obsession de la France
et en particulier plutôt des
conservateurs français de toujours
soupçonner l'Allemagne ce qu'on appelle
le l'idée de Rapallo c'est à dire de la
potentielle
guérison capacité de l'Allemagne
disposition de l'Allemagne a trahir en
se tournant vers l'est c'est on dit même
en français le drague narrosnan sauf que
la géographie c'est une donnée et que
c'est plutôt probablement un problème de
perception de la France de se trouver
naturellement plus à la périphérie c'est
vrai au bord de la mer et que
l'Allemagne a un voisinage immédiat avec
la Pologne et les anciens autres pays de
l'Est et je rappelle que la France a été
très engagée dans le Triangle de Weimar
en considérant qu'il était impossible de
laisser le troisième très grand pays
d'Europe continental qui est la Pologne
en dehors d'un projet commun donc ça
fait partie je pense aussi de querelle
franco-française et de soit jouer à se
faire peur soit considérer que les
probables faiblesses que l'on a tiennent
au voisin je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens en Allemagne qui ont pas du tout
envie d'être le leadership le centre de
gravité de d'être en très grande
proximité avec les pays de l'Est il y a
des gens qui qui sont très très
favorables à de bonnes relations avec la
Russie mais quand vous parlez avec
beaucoup d'Allemands qui vont vous dire
que ils se sentent pas particulièrement
attirés par l'Est et pour le commerce
parce que vous parliez de la Chine mais
est-ce que l'Allemagne commerce possible
énormément avec la Russie enfin jusqu'à
la guerre pour la Russie c'était une
dépendance au gaz mais c'était la même
comment dire c'était la même idéologie
qui qui comment dire qui motivait la
relation à la Russie cette croyance que
le commerce allait apporter la pelle
libéralisme c'est la politique de paix
par le commerce qui a été officiellement
abandonnée d'ailleurs par l'Allemagne au
printemps mais qui a guidé la politique
étrangère allemande pendant 40 ans cette
espèce de croyance fondamentalement très
libérale d'ailleurs de dire on va faire
grossir les entreprises comme ça les
intérêts privés finiront par peser sur
l'intérêt public et comme la guerre
n'est pas dans les intérêts privés il
aura plus de guerre on voit bien que
c'est tout ça s'effondre comme un
château de cartes et que c'était une
immense erreur d'ailleurs un autre
dernier acte de l'air Merkel ça a été
quand même de pousser à fond dans ce
stream 2 et oh la je disais encore au
mois de février que Nord Stream 2 était
un projet privé tellement privé que
Gazprom a servi de bras armé au chantage
de Vladimir Poutine l'Europe donc il y a
eu quand même des erreurs majeures des
fautes historiques qu'il faut que
l'Allemagne reconnaisse sincèrement leur
propre centrale le dit aussi avec nous
en cœur parce que elle elle est en
première porte de la de l'impérialisme
de la lutte contre l'impérialisme mais
voilà je crois qu'on est dans un moment
historique où il faut donc il faut tire
les passionnant c'est l'Allemagne
confronté à l'obligation de changer le
modèle les conséquences de cette
situation sur le duo franco-allemand et
dans ce contexte on va dire de brouille
ou de désaccord je propose de nous
rejoindre tout de suite il y a
évidemment rebonsoir Audrey toutes les
questions de défense oui tout a pourtant
commencé par une bonne nouvelle en
apparence pour la France avec la guerre
en Ukraine et face à la menace
l'Allemagne a annoncé qu'elle allait
fortement investir dans sa défense
écouter
prête à assumer une responsabilité de
premier plan pour la sécurité de notre
continent
elle annonce 100 milliards d'euros pour
moderniser son armée elle promet aussi
d'y consacrer 2% de son PIB c'est ce que
demande l'OTAN mais jusqu'à présent ce
n'était pas le contenu n'était pas en
Allemagne alors dans un premier temps la
France se réjouit l'Allemagne va enfin
prendre sa part dans la défense
européenne elle va très vite déchanter
car les Allemands veulent s'armer
rapidement et ils se tournent vers les
Américains à qui il commande 35 avions
de chasse F35 tout ça alors que la
France est le troisième exportateur
d'armes au monde première divergence ça
va s'accentuer oui quant à mi-octobre
l'Allemagne annonce qu'elle va
participer à un projet de bouclier
aérien européen avec plusieurs pays de
l'OTAN un bouclier qui s'appuie sur une
technologie israélienne la France reste
à l'écart elle elle a un projet de
protection aérienne avec l'Italie en
fait ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'Allemagne n'a pas l'arme de dissuasion
nucléaire et donc elle a cherché un
moyen rapide de se protéger d'une
attaque ça a créé de grosses dissensions
pardon avec la France ça a peut-être
même été l'une des gouttes d'eau qui a
provoqué l'annulation vous en avez parlé
du Conseil des ministres franco-allemand
allez peut-être un message d'espoir
est-ce qu'il y a un espoir que les
choses s'arrangent oui car les deux
hommes se sont rencontrés en tête à tête
Emmanuel Macron et olafolle s'il y a
quelques jours pour aplanir ses
dissensions et voici ce qu'a récemment
dit Emmanuel Macron par rapport à
l'Allemagne d'abord notre volonté de
renforcer les liens avec l'Allemagne
bien sûr partenaire indispensable avec
lequel nous sommes engagés dans des
programmes profondément structurants nos
forces sont faites pour se combiner
excellent industriel partagé évidemment
mais aussi réalité opérationnelle et
ambition stratégique et de l'équilibre
de notre partenariat dépend je le crois
aussi pour partie la réussite du projet
européen
on vient d'apprendre que le projet
d'avion du futur européen porté par
l'Allemagne la France et l'Espagne
venait d'être débloqué la première phase
de construction d'un démonstrateur
devrait être lancé d'ici la fin de
l'année merci beaucoup Audrey betas pour
toutes ces précisions Brita il faut
peut-être commencer en disant ce que ce
que représente la décision de
l'Allemagne de consacrer 2% de son
budget à la défense de ce réarmer en
quelque sorte c'est quand même un virage
majeur quoi il faut il faut l'expliquer
c'est ce que annoncé dans cette dans ce
discours où il a parlé de ça 22
changement d'époque
c'est à dire que l'armée allemande était
réduit à des missions bien spéciales et
l'étranger intervenir à l'étranger ou
même intervenir dans les quatre
catastrophes à l'intérieur du pays donc
on se voyait plus du tout comme comme
une armée classique c'est presque une
armée humanitaire en quelque sorte
j'exagère
en situation de crise c'est c'est à
l'étranger ou à l'intérieur donc et puis
bon la demande de la part des États-Unis
que l'Allemagne participe aux
remplissent ce lieu pour cent de son
budget était là depuis longtemps donc
maintenant actuellement c'est 50
milliards je crois par an et il faudrait
que pour remplir les deux pour moi ça
dépend de mais c'est ça serait 75
milliards donc c'est vraiment une grande
ambition donc tout d'abord c'est un
changement vraiment assez brutal accepté
par l'opinion publique bizarrement
bizarrement c'était c'était assez vite
plutôt favorable par rapport à ce qu'il
a dit mais bon la guerre il joue
certainement beaucoup donc après oui je
sais que là on peut on peut dire je sais
pas si tout à l'heure vous avez dit il
est mal conseillé moi je crois que
parfois il y a des
[Musique]
pourquoi il y a le général de
l'inspecteur général de la Bundes sphère
qui au mois de septembre a dit on
voulait prendre quelque chose qui vole
qui marche qui fonctionne et qui est sur
le marché et qui était déjà prêt donc
Chloé vous l'avez un peu évoqué dans
dans les nouveaux interventions mais à
quel point alors là on est vraiment sur
le focus militaire mais ça ça fragilise
la place ou le poids de l'Allemagne en
Europe c'est ces derniers choix de de la
chose c'est assez choix de de
l'avion vers Israël pour le parce que
c'est regrettable je vais pas vous dire
autrement la construction d'une défense
européenne autonome aujourd'hui elle est
plus que nécessaire sauf que cette
guerre l'a fait reculer cet objectif
puisqu'il ne l'a fait avancer puisqu'il
a renforcé l'OTAN et le 100% au temps je
ne vais pas jeter la pierre sur la fin
non et la Suède qui intègre le temps il
y a pas d'alternative pour ceux qui
cherchent la protection aujourd'hui
c'est bien tout le problème et je crois
aussi que malheureusement les États-Unis
ont démontré qu'ils étaient un parapluie
militaire et nucléaire plus performant
que la France parce que inchiné à la fin
des fins si on veut construire une
défense européenne autonome faudra
qu'elle repose sur le parapluie
nucléaire français peut-être par un prix
nucléaire britannique mais c'est moins
certain et donc tout l'enjeu consiste à
montrer que nous Français nous sommes
crédibles et plus crédible que les
Américains pour protéger les autres
d'accord je crois que c'est la route est
longue Hélène maire de la Croix si on se
place du côté allemand est-ce que
finalement c'est pas compréhensible les
choix de l'absols il voulait aller vite
il voulait rassurer peut-être son
opinion publique il faut je pense aussi
pour regarder bien les choix de la boule
de SVR il faut bien se rappeler que la
Baume de svers non seulement elle a sur
tout servi à des interventions
humanitaires ou lorsqu'il y avait des
inondations mais elle est dans un état
catastrophique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu
des enquêtes qui ont montré que le
matériel que porte les soldats et dans
un état catastrophique et donc il y a eu
une espèce d'électrochoc et quand vous
dites à la boule de sphère donc à
l'armée allemande donc aux officiers
voilà on vous donne de l'argent
modernisé le mieux possible
quelle est la réaction d'un officier de
la Bundes vertes il va chercher du
matériel américain alors certes parce
qu'il est sur l'étagère comme il a dit
mais c'est parce que c'est c'est le
logiciel il faut pas il faut pas oublier
comment la boule de sueur a été créée le
5 mai 1955 parce que il y a eu au mois
de fin août 1954 l'échec de la
Communauté européenne de défense à
l'Assemblée nationale française qui a
refusé de d'ouvrir le dossier et que
donc le la solution au temps a été la
seule possibilité d'armer l'Allemagne et
donc contribuer à la défense de l'Europe
dans un système où l'on ne pouvait pas
se trop enfin s'inquiéter de des
Allemands et donc pour la Bundes VR pour
les officiers de la Bundes verts c'est
évident qu'on va utiliser le matériel un
que l'on connaît dans un système dans
lequel on est intégré et et il faudrait
que le politique là est une force de
persuasion énorme pour convaincre qu'en
plus il faut aller
empêcher les dispute entre d'assaut d'un
côté Airbus Allemagne de l'autre côté
parce qu'il y a aussi cette dimension là
dans l'avion les projets d'avion du
projet skalf il y a du côté allemand le
soupçon que nouvelle le nouveau chasseur
européen serait un Rafale plus et en
fait servir et les intérêts français il
faut pas l'oublier ça qu'il y a aussi
une petite ben oui je pense que les deux
amis
catastrophique parce que on peut pas la
sécurité européenne ne peut pas dépendre
de ce que vote les électeurs américains
ont vraiment
American est déstabilisée c'est tragique
que l'Allemagne prenne des décisions qui
nous emmènent à 10-15 ans sur le choix
des bombardiers F35 on termine là-dessus
merci beaucoup c'était passionnant merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat chlory
d'Algérie le titre de votre livre d'une
guerre l'autre livre publié aux éditions
de l'eau de voilà fin de cette émission
merci encore une fois à toutes et à tous
de votre fidélité votre prochain
rendez-vous sur notre antenne
rendez-vous politique évidemment c'est
le président du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale Olivier Marnay qui s'inviter
de la matinale et face à rayonnementcini
c'est à 8 heures du matin belle soirée
[Musique]